aujourd'hui pour notre calendrier de
l'avent 100 % yvinois je vous propose de
découvrir un livre de cuisine pas comme
les
[Musique]
autres un livre de cuisine avec les
recettes préférées des joueurs du PSG le
paris-germain est le premier club à
faire un livre de cuisine
189 pages avec le chef doublement étoilé
David tain dans ce livre on retrouve 70
recettes pour varier ses repas une
dizaine de joueurs du PSG se sont prêtés
au jeu et chacun a donné SEP recettes de
cuisine on retrouve par exemple couscous
d'enfance d'Ashraf Hakimi ou encore les
crêpes de pressnel kipemb l'occasion
aussi dans cet ouvrage de découvrir
différentes recettes du monde entier à
travers les différentes nationalités des
joueurs du PSG le livre paru aux
éditions enforite au tarif de
24,90 € de quoi ravir tous les gourmands
Paris et
magique